gonna begin with this weather of course
because March is still coming in like a
lion in the Northeast where the second
big storm in five days is likely to
cause more widespread damage
oh no heavy snow it started falling
early this morning in Washington DC it's
now spreading across the region this
developing nor'easter will bring snow
and strong winds to many communities
that were hit hard last weekend the
storm could dump a foot or more of snow
in parts of New York and New England
winter storm warnings are up from
eastern Pennsylvania to Maine more than
100,000 people who are still without
power because of last week's nor'easter
could face new disruption Don Dahler is
in Bala Cynwyd Pennsylvania just
northwest of Philadelphia which is still
recovering from the last storm Don good
morning good morning I'm standing in
front of a house here in this
Philadelphia suburb that was almost
split in two by a falling tree last week
there were people inside fortunately
they were not injured and hopefully
they're sleeping safe and sound
somewhere else but this really
illustrates the dangers that all the
people are facing all up and down the
East Coast now this is incredibly wet
and heavy snow it adds a lot of weight
to the tops of these old trees and their
root systems have already been weakened
by this storm last week in fact I want
to show you this this is the tree that
fell on that house and you can see just
how massive and old it is it couldn't
stand up to those winds this also shows
you the risk not only for the residents
but for these utility crews that have
been out day and night trying to restore
electricity to tens of thousands of
customers the streets are still littered
with branches and trees and power lines
and those power lines are no joke in
fact I want to show you some video from
New York City where an electrical line
fell down next to some police officers
and some other cars now the determinant
factor as to whether this storm is going
to be as damaging as last week's the
winds we are told they're not supposed
to be as intense as last week but they
still could be gusting upwards of 60
miles an hour it's gonna be a long day
John Don thanks